hablemos de la capacidad buffer la
capacidad buffer es una propiedad de las
soluciones buffer también conocidas como
soluciones amortiguadores y nos dice que
tanto ha sido base podemos agregar antes
de que el ph cambia básicamente conforme
la capacidad buffer aumenta lo voy a
abreviar como cp conforme la capacidad
buffer aumenta podemos agregar más de
nuestro ácido o de nuestra base antes de
que el ph empiece a cambiar mucho
esta definición se ve muy vaga pero
hagamos un ejemplo para ver qué
significa exactamente veamos un ejemplo
donde usemos ácido acético como nuestro
buffer ácido acético sh3d o h
y para no decirlo todo vamos a abreviar
lo como h
y se encuentra en solución acuosa y es
una reacción reversible en donde se
forma el lyon h más
dice h3c o menos o acetato entonces para
este ejemplo vamos a abreviar el acetato
como a menos y bueno más información
sobre esta solución buffer en particular
es que el caa para el ácido acético es
igual a 1.8 por 10 a la menos 5 y si
sacamos el menos logaritmo de eso
obtenemos el pk a que también es útil el
pk
del ácido acético es 4.74 esto nos dice
mucho sobre el comportamiento de la
solución buffer y bueno lo último que
necesitamos saber para
predecir el comportamiento de nuestro
buffer es la relación entre el h
y el a menos vamos a ver tenemos una
solución buffer donde a menos
/ h
es igual a 1.82 basándonos en esta
relación podemos calcular el ph entonces
el ph inicial de la solución buffer
antes de que agreguemos algún ácido base
lo vamos a calcular usando la ecuación
de henderson hash el back esa ecuación
nos dice que el ph es igual al pk
más el logaritmo de la concentración de
a menos o acetato entre la concentración
de ácido acético si no se sienten muy
seguros de usar esta ecuación o quieren
saber de dónde viene tenemos otros
vídeos sobre eso les recomiendo que los
vea en este vídeo vamos a usar esta
ecuación tal como está entonces vamos a
sustituir nuestros valores
sabemos que el pk inicial es igual a 4
punto 74
+ el logaritmo de 1.82 que es la
relación de a menos entre h
así que el ph inicial es igual a 5.00
que ahora vamos a analizar dos
soluciones buffer diferentes
las dos están hechas de ácido acético y
acetato vamos a llamar las buffer 1 y
buffer 2 entonces buffer 1 tiene una
relación a menos h a igual a 1.82 así
que el ph es igual a 5 y la
concentración de a menos antes de que
agreguemos algo es 0.90 molar y la
concentración de h a es 0.49 molar y al
segundo buffer con el que vamos a
comparar vamos a llamarlo buffer 2 esta
solución también tiene la misma relación
ha sido base excepto que las dos
concentraciones van a ser diez veces más
pequeñas que las de la buffer 1 así que
la concentración de a menos es 0.0 90
molar y la concentración de ácido
acético es 0.0 49 molar entonces vamos a
ver qué pasa con el ph de estas dos
soluciones miren al inicio las dos
tienen un ph de 5 pero que tanto
cambiará cuando agreguemos 0.04 moles
de una base fuerte hidróxido de sodio
a un litro de solución buffer
bueno como es una solución buffer o
amortiguador a sabemos que resistirá el
cambio de ph pero qué es lo que ocurre
exactamente cuál es la reacción cuando
agregamos eso bueno cuando agregamos la
base fuerte que se disocia para formar o
h - va a reaccionar con el ácido en la
solución buffer entonces nuestro ácido s
h3c o h
y siempre suponemos que una base fuerte
reacciona irreversiblemente entonces
pondremos una flecha con un solo sentido
cuando tenemos un ácido débil
y aquí lo que pasa es que este protón
reacciona con él
para formar h2o agua y nos queda de h3c
o menos esta es nuestra base y observen
que el hidróxido reaccionará uno a uno
con nuestro ácido débil produciendo un
equivalente de nuestra base entonces ya
podemos usar esta información para
calcular lo que ocurre con nuestro
buffer cuando agregamos 0.04 moles de
hidróxido de sodio y lo que sucede es
que va a reaccionar con nuestro ácido
eso significa que la concentración del
ácido acético disminuye 0.04 molar así
que la nueva concentración después de
que reacciona es 0.45 molar
y qué ocurre con la concentración de la
base bueno
recuerden que cuando el ácido reaccione
con el hidróxido de sodio se produce más
fácil así que necesitamos ajustar la
concentración de a menos porque aumenta
cuando ocurre la reacción agregamos 0.04
moles de acetato y por lo tanto la nueva
concentración de lyon acetato es 0.94
molar estas son nuestras concentraciones
finales y ahora vamos a sustituir las de
nuevo en la ecuación de henderson hazel
back para calcular el ph entonces el ph
de la solución buffer 1 pondré el
subíndice 1 es igual a 4.74 el pk más el
logaritmo de 0.94 molar entre 0.45 molar
y si usamos la calculadora obtenemos que
el ph después de agregar el hidróxido es
5 puntos
pero 6 aumentó 0.06 y eso tiene sentido
porque sabíamos que sería más alto ya
que si agregamos una base se vuelve más
básico y por lo tanto el ph aumenta pero
no cambia mucho porque recuerden que es
una solución buffer ok ahora comparemos
esto con el buffer 2 si agregamos 0.04
moles de hidróxido de sodio entonces la
concentración de ácido acético disminuye
0.04 molar por lo tanto la nueva
concentración de h a es igual a 0.009
molar y por la misma reacción la
concentración de la base aumenta como el
ácido reacciona y se produce más base
conjugada vamos a agregar 0.04 molar a
la concentración de a menos y nos queda
que la nueva concentración es
0.13 molar ok ahora vamos a sustituir
esas concentraciones en la ecuación de
henderson hasselbeck tenemos que el ph
de nuestro buffer 2 es igual a 4 puntos
74 el pk
más putts más el logaritmo de 0.3 se
molar entre 0.009 molar si usamos la
calculadora esto es igual a 1.16 y al
sumar todo nos queda que el ph es igual
a 5.90 así que el ph cambio más en el
buffer 2 que en el buffer 1 el ph
aumentó 0.9 en lugar de 0.06 así que
comparando la capacidad buffer de estas
dos soluciones podemos decir que el ph
cambia menos cuando agregamos la misma
cantidad de ácido o base y por lo tanto
la solución buffer 1 tiene una mayor
capacidad buffer
y como no queremos que estas
concentraciones a menos y h
sean muy bajas la regla de oro es que
las concentraciones de h
y amenos estén entre 0.3 molar y 1.0
molar siguiendo esta regla de oro pueden
hacer una solución buffer donde no
tengan que preocuparse por agregar mucho
ácido o base antes de que el ph cambie
ya que normalmente por eso hacemos una
solución buffer o amortiguador